مراسلتنا شيماء اهلا بك شيماء اذا تصريحات
جديده من الخارجيه الصينيه ومن المسؤولين
الصينيين وخطوات متلاحقه حديث عن عزم
الصين اقامه منطقه حضر طيران شمال تايوان
ماذا في دقه هذه المعلومات
نعم مريم بالنسبه لمنطقه حظر الطيران من
تاريخ 16 حتى التاسع عشر من الشهر الجاري
فكانت وزاره الخارجيه الصناع قد تحفظت ولم
تعلق على الموضوع لكن صدر عن الجهات
اليابانيه او عن الحكومه اليابانيه القول
ان الصين كانت قد اختارتها بهذا الموضوع
وبان هنالك حظرا للطيران في المنطقه
الشماليه من جزيره تايوان سوف تتم خلال
الفتره من السادس عشر حتى التاسع عشر ولكن
ليس بغايه عسكريه بل ان الصين سوف تقوم
باطلاق قمر صناعي في تلك الفتره لذلك قامت
باخطار دول المنطقه بما فيها الحكومه
التايوانيه فيما يتعلق بحذر الطيران من
جهه اخرى تصريحات عديده شديده اللهجه على
اكثر من مستوى نتحدث عن وزاره الدفاع
والجيش الصيني صباح اليوم الذي اكد بانه
يواصل تدريباته العسكريه القتاليه
والهجوميه في منطقه بحر جندوب الصين وفي
منطقه مضيق تايوان تحديدا حوالي جزيره
تايوان بالرغم من اعلانه صباح يوم الاثنين
عن انتهاء العسكريه التي استمرت لثلاثه
ايام متواصله ابتداء من يوم السبت والى
حدود يوم الاثنين والانتقال بانها كانت
رساله واضحه للجهات التايوانيه وايضا
للجانب الامريكي بعد زياره الرئيس
التايوانيه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولقائها رغم اعتراض الصين برئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن مكارسي هنالك
تصريحات شديده اللهجه ايضا صدرت عن
المتحدثه باسم مكتب شؤون تايوان التابعه
للحكومه الصينيه صباح هذا اليوم خلال
مؤتمر الصحفي اكدت بان تايوان جزء لا
يتجزا من اراضي الصين وعلى كل دول المنطقه
والدول العالم ان تحترم مبدا استقلاليه
مبدا الصين واحده وعدم الدفاع او دعم مبدا
استقلاليه تايوان عن المراه الرئيسيه
للصين هنالك ايضا تحذيرات شديده اللهجه من
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه قبل قليل على
اللسان المتحدث باسم اوامبيه عندما قال
بان اي الدول في العالم او قوى خارجيه تح
الدفاع عن مبدا استقلال التايوان عن
المراه الرئيسيه للصين فهذه الجهود سوف
تبوء بالفشل تحدث ايضا بصفه غير مباشره
عندما قال بان هنالك دولا تحاول ان تحتمي
بدول خارجيه وقوى خارجيه وان ذلك لن
يفيدها بل سيتسبب في زعزعه امن واستقرار
المنطقه وسوف يتسبب ايضا في مزيد من
التوترات الاقليميه والدوليه الصين اليوم
مريم في حاله من
الهجوم على عده اصعده هنالك عده دول في
العالم تحاول انشاء تحالفات تهاجم من خلال
الصين وهذا بحسب تصريحات المسؤولين
الصينيين الصينيه اليوم ايضا تحدثت عن
بيان مشترك بين كل من الفلبين والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه صدر بالامس وعربت عن
قلقها واستيائها من هذا البيان الذي يضع
الصين كاكبر تهديد عالمي شيماء شكرا جزيلا
لك